it sounds extraordinary in terms of a
challenge but this is something
that actually quite a few people have
tried to do in the past but no one's
ever managed it you seem to be well on
your way
yes you can imagine an island like great
britain the conditions the weather the
wind that we have
um is always fairly brutal and the tidal
streams are so strong
that lots of people have tried and
unfortunately not necessarily been able
to achieve it
so this is where i've come in and you
know what i'm pretty close to setting
the first world record which will be
from paddling
from land's end to john o'groats and i'm
about 30k from john o'groats right now
in the north of scotland where it must
be 50 mile an hour winds outside this
van hence why i'm in a van
talking to you with the oakley isles
behind me wow i mean look
it's beautiful scenery but how hard
going is it i mean if you
if you're 30 miles away i mean so what
sort of time does it take to cover that
yeah i mean my biggest day is just under
80k
in a day my shortest day was 2k
just going around with some of the
gnarly headlands where it's
you know 12 foot swell and 40 mile an
hour winds you can't really get much
done
but um you know i've had lots of
beautiful days as well as bad days
on the board but the whole reason i'm
doing this is promote water safety in a
time where
so many people are trying to go out on
the water whether they're swimming in
wild swimming
or indeed paddle boarding so trying to
promote good practice
and showing that actually we can
appreciate and make the most of our
environment but doing it safely yeah i
mean i know whether you've got a
particular mind in
young people and water safety haven't
you yeah absolutely um
you know on this island nation we
unfortunately for lots of different
reasons don't teach our children water
safety annually
um and this is why i came up with this
idea to paddle board britain so
the media will talk to me and we can
promote and uh
make some money to actually create the
world's first gamified app for children
to play
and learn about their local beach learn
about their local inland waterway canal
river whatever
and try and stay safe at a time when so
many more of us want to get out into the
world and enjoy the wildlife
especially on a stand-up paddleboard
yeah
absolutely look brendan good luck good
to see you
god bless thank you very much have a
great day
you